we didn't appreciate the scale of danger
until the rounds just started coming in
anybody approaching the fence or trying
to break through
risks their life they'll be shot I think
the thing that you understand very very
quickly is that people are frustrated
you can use the analogy of a powder keg
about to blow there's not much work the
economy is broken the infrastructure
within Gaza whether it's sewage water
electricity it's really collapsing I
mean it's a humanitarian disaster in
everything but name to understand Gaza
you need to understand the refugee issue
and the centrality of that within the
Palestinian narrative these are people
who were forced out of their homes or
fled during the creation of Israel in
1948 more than two-thirds of the
population of more than 2 million people
are refugees they will often tell you
and point out that they are living in
the biggest open-air prison in the world
it's under blockade the Israel controls
what goes in and what goes out they want
the world to see what they have to put
up with and why they want you to go to
the fence over this period of time
[Music]
Ezreal would argue that they withdrew
unilaterally in 2005 but they still
control everything that goes in by lands
they can say what garson's can have or
not have they control the airspace and
they also control the area from the city
it's under a blockade at the moment now
Palestinians would say it's a form of
siege Israel argues that it is to stop
Hamas Hamas is a militant is the missed
organization now they have called many
times in the past for the destruction of
Israel and this is why Israel justifies
a blockade of Gaza it's a place that is
always on the cusp of breaking out into
a kind of violent reaction with Israel
at some point so the protests that
started on March the 30th they were
about reclaiming what they see as their
natural rights to the land that they
belong to so when the protests started
they weren't to highlight what it is to
be a Palestinian
- as far as they're concerned be
incarcerated with no hope with no
opportunity and to have been for many
years denied what they see as their
rights to their land I mean yeah this is
my country
Israel's narrative from the office been
that this has been organized by Hamas
and it's being used as a camouflage for
terrorist activity whilst there are
people protesting on the border
distracting the Israeli Defense Forces
others will be breaking through the
fence and then go into the settlements
the Israeli settlements which are dotted
around the Gaza Strip those people will
go in there to commit terrible terrorist
acts but how do you deal with that where
you have huge numbers of people butting
up against the fence those people are
mostly unarmed they might have
slingshots they might have Molotov
cocktails how do you deal those people
and how do you prevent a mass breach of
the Defense
they've dealt with it by using tear gas
initially once you get a large number of
people live ammunition started being
employed these demonstrations are taking
place at five locations along the Gaza
Strip with the border with Israel we're
here in the sound of Israeli snipers
firing this man you see here
he's just been hit in his foot I don't
know what he was doing leading up to
that but he is unarmed and he was just
picked off by an Israeli sniper he's
probably about a hundred meters 150
meters from the border feds Joe has just
been shot
from what we could see aiming at
people's legs their feet and in some
cases their chests or even their heads
we're expecting a lot of hinges I don't
think anyone quite expected it to be on
that scale Israel had made it very clear
saying anybody approaching the fence or
trying to break through risks their life
they'll be shot
people knew that the boss going to be a
large number of casualties and a large
number of dead and that proved to be the
case being the center of it was
extremely strained in a war zone for
instance if people start shooting at you
and you hear bullets fitting very close
to you you get behind cover you get down
you get half of the way we were hoping
of course that we were marked as press
and we wouldn't be targeted ourselves
although journalists have been shot by
the Israeli forces but around you people
are dropping it's very hard to kind of
process there's a disconnect in your
mind about what exactly is happening
you'll hear the shots and then you'll
see somebody who's fallen to the floor
and then the crowd will move back
slightly and they'll all start moving
forwards again to the fence
it seems so avoidable what is it that
makes these people who are largely
unarmed do this why how why here it's
just it's astonishing it's just hard to
process mentally their resilience is
amazing we would see a number of
protesters who had been shot in previous
days some of these kids coming back with
metal splints the fact that people will
go back time and time again and protest
and risk their lives even when they've
already been injured is testament to
quite how strong this sense of
desperation is you just didn't know what
was gonna happen
to the right so wherever you were moving
you know all of a sudden somebody to the
left or somebody to the right of you
collapse having been shot it was very
dangerous I think we didn't appreciate
the scale of the danger until the rounds
just started coming in you only have to
look at the fact that young Palestinian
journalists were were killed whilst
clearly wearing equipment that
identified them as press medics have
also been shots injured and killed as a
result of healthy people now the Israeli
claim is that they are using enough
force only enough force to protect their
borders it was chance really where
you're standing not so much who you were
or what you were doing just where you
were standing at any particular moment
and that sort of decided whether you
would get hits one heart
I mean it's frightening and it's
distressing it's important to get in the
midst of it as much as possible I think
that's the only way that it's really
going to sink in and the viewers mind if
you can show them those close-up
pictures we tried to make sure that we
weren't too far in with the protesters
but were somewhat to the side so that
our press markings were clear on our
flak jackets so hopefully it was easy
for the Israeli forces to identify who
we were it does make you wonder is it
gonna be you next
the disparity with power who has the
power is glaringly obvious you know
Israel has one of the the most modern
and sophisticated armies but on the
other side you have the Palestinians in
these protests the inventiveness has
lent itself to using kites they've got
sort of flaming rags on the back of them
and they're being sent across the border
and then they are landing in dry Israeli
arable fields and they're setting fire
to them causing you know millions of
pounds worth of damage it has frustrated
the Israeli military so much so that it
could really be the catalyst for the
next outbreak in conflict that you see
between Hamas and Gaza and the Israelis
but it certainly has changed the dynamic
to try and negotiate a lifting of some
of the sanctions involved in the
blockade
[Music]
[Music]
we stopped at one of the field hospitals
and the scenes were quite horrific I
think I saw about 15 ambulances come in
each one loaded with three four or five
people all with lower leg wounds the
triage center was overflowing injured
body after injured body coming in it was
heartbreaking it was heartbreaking to
see quite how quickly people were
getting hurt
[Music]
by the end of the day you are attending
the first funerals people who were at
the protests that you were at in the
morning you invariably are welcome the
people want the world to see what they
are giving to resist their lives and
that their suffering is
[Music]
[Music]
I think certainly the Palestinians think
that these processes have been enormous
ly successful this was one of very few
means that they had at their disposal to
say look we're here we need to be heard
people are watching gasser again and
people are looking at what's happening
there when you talk to some of the young
lads that have lost limbs and have been
shot in the leg you know they back at
the fence again and and that's like two
or three days later so that's what it
means to them it's a way of negotiating
with Israel it's a way of moving the
dial in a certain direction but the
danger of course is that what actually
ends up happening is these protests will
slowly but inevitably morph into
something else because of that constant
friction and that constant clash on the
border with the Israeli forces and then
it doesn't take very long before you're
entering a new phase where you'll see
rockets going out of Gaza and you're
seeing Israeli warplanes bombing the
Strip again
[Music]